i want to see a movie with a bunch of uh
poogles and fairy aishas that's what i
want give it to i don't know what's
happening this is i'm talking about
neopets
she had an aneurysm i've only read
yeah i taste pennies is that normal
what's a great film that you are glad
never got a sequel
well brian i was looking at uh the
article of that same title on on a
little website called looper.com and
i've heard of that website yeah as have
i and
uh yeah uh it has so many movies that i
love very very much on it and that i
agree with wholeheartedly i'm thrilled
that casablanca does not have like
casablanca 2 you know
back in morocco or whatever
casas blancas yeah
i'm glad inception didn't continue
because it's it closes on such a good
button uh pulp fiction is a long time
favorite and i don't even want to think
about what a sequel would have been um
and i ended up going with something on
the list but i want to present my
honorable mention first because it's a
movie that
uh that i love very much that was a huge
comedy hit and that i believe there have
been many attempts to
kind of ring a sequel out of it but they
haven't been successful because the
screenwriters just don't want to do it
and they're smart um and that's
bridesmaids
which was a huge huge huge hit you know
crushed the box office great reviews was
nominated for academy awards you know
for melissa mccarthy and for its
screenplay uh written by kristen wiig
and her friend annie momolo
and i believe that
this you know
i believe that the the powers that be
behind bridesmaids have wanted a sequel
for years because of how profitable it
was
but kristen wiig and annie manuel have
just been like no we're done we're done
telling that story like let it let it
rest and i'm really happy because i
think a sequel would probably be about
like my rudolph's character having a
baby and it would kind of just play the
same beats of the first one and it just
i don't think it would be good
wait a minute another hangover what if
they called it brides and they all got
married at the same time
that would be bad brian that would be a
bad movie that i don't want to see no
it's like a dollar's worth of bad brian
i don't see a way that they could avoid
like the hangover kind of curse of that
where they just do the same thing for
three movies to increasingly diminish
returns and also what that led to is
instead of working on you know
bridesmaids two brides or whatever your
idea was um
uh chris
yeah it's been so long but what this led
to is kristen wiggins
brian that's a really really good idea
um what this led to i'm going to
continue with some dignity left maybe um
uh because christian wig and andy mullow
had like an oscar nomination under their
belt and a ton of financial studio
success they got to make the weirdest
movie of 2020. near and dear to my heart
barbie star and star vista del mar yes
and like
if that's i consider that a spiritual
sequel to bridesmaids and it's
if you haven't seen it please watch it i
think it's on hulu right now if you
don't think that you want to see jamie
dornan dancing down a beach and doing
pirouettes and singing his heart out
then you're just wrong you're very wrong
would you want to see that but okay my
real pick i got off topic is oh that was
social network okay my real pick is the
social network which is one of my
all-time favorite movies
everyone who knows me
pretty well knows that i have a really
bitter grudge against king speech which
is a fine movie but it should not have
beaten social network for best picture
and i will die on that hill
you should just
yeah
it's cleaner
did you just whack your mic
anyway i'm gonna continue as if nothing
happened um no social network is um
should have been a best picture winner
no a very acclaimed movie great cast
great writing great direction
everything about it comes together it's
such a tightly paced and edited and just
every aspect of the movie i think for me
works on every single level and like it
also is smart and that it specifically
focuses on you know the inception and
college years of facebook rather than
like the modern kind of behemoth that
facebook has become and with all the
weird you know legal troubles that that
whole company has faced in the past
couple of years through elections and
through all sorts of stuff i mean i
don't want to see that like continue
that would be a really upsetting and
potentially very dull movie i mean
there's going to be a documentary about
it eventually that i'll watch and talk
about at a dinner party or whatever but
like
it's not it's not a sequel i want to see
and i also think that none of the people
would come back for it so it would just
be very bad like it would be like some
you know cut-rate aaron sorkin acolyte
and like someone who looks kind of like
jesse eisenberg but isn't him
yeah
i didn't want to say michael sarah
because i wanted to give him a little
more credit than that but you're right
it would be michael sarah poor michael
sarah
yeah just kept talking
yeah it would be
andrew garfield yeah
to play eduardo
yeah i think this movie might be kind of
good i don't know
can we do exactly what we're talking
about here but it's the origin of
myspace
who's going to play tom i think bradley
cooper should play tom from myspace
mm-hmm oh no that's what i'm saying
bring in michael's
bring in the off-brand bring in the
kirkland signature versions of all of
the actors
the story of friendster
yeah
the story of zanga and livejournal yeah
all right
this is neopets
oh
okay no now you're just describing a
bunch of movies i want to watch is the
problem i would totally watch a gritty
biopic about the foundation of neopets
of course i'd watch that scientology was
involved in that eventually it kind of
like christian bail in there i watched
i'm sure like we can you know i'm sure i
can find a link and we can put it in the
description but there is like a
long-form youtube video about like the
weird shady stuff behind neopets and
it's fascinating
um yeah neopets was a was a uh a big
touchstone for me so yeah social network
i don't want to see remade unless it's
about myspace friendsterzenga live
journal or neopets in which case i want
to see it
i want to see a movie with a bunch of uh
poogles and fairy aishas that's what i
want give it to i don't know what's
happening this is i'm talking about
neopets
she had an aneurysm i've only read
yeah i taste pennies is that normal
no get them out of your mouth
there's a couple on this article that i
responded to
um one was logan lucky which i saw
pretty recently which i liked a bunch
that was a good heist movie and i do
agree that i think a sequel to that
would definitely
diminish some of the the special
weirdness that happens in that film it's
a fun movie it's a really fun movie and
a lot of that has to do with daniel
craig playing joe bang
um which also kind of brings up you know
this interesting we've talked about this
before the sequel to knives out uh not
knives in um
i love
i love yeah more knives
knife crime you're welcome i think i
just blew a booger out of my nose thank
you
knife crimes
uh thank you uh welcome inside jokes
they happen here too um
no so but the reason i bring it up right
because daniel craig plays benoit blank
and he's amazing i love that movie i'm
really excited to see a sequel but part
of me also likes to think like that
would have been great as just a
standalone film right you can just
revisit and say do you want more knives
out
watch the movie again here it is there's
no chance that it will disappoint you
because it's the same movie it was i
mean i will make the rebuttal though
that like this i do i like the idea of
like the agatha christie kind of hercule
baro thing that they're clearly doing
with benoit blanc where it's like put
him in a different situation he'll be
himself and then you get a cast of
a-listers to surround him right no i
agree i'm excited to see what they do
but but you know i i do think back to
like you know movies like logan lucky
that are so singular so
weird and that definitely could have
sequels it has franchise potential but
you know unfortunately for them
unfortunately for us it didn't do very
well so they're not going to make one so
you just have this one strange
southern gothic
comedy heist film
and it just works and the other one that
you mentioned was inception which is a
really good example of a great movie
that again has that sequel potential you
could go in all different directions
with it and thank goodness that they
didn't well i mean aside from batman i
don't think christopher nolan's much in
the sequel business is he i mean
no
but i mean that's the thing i can't
think of a single movie he's made that's
not batman that has a sequel beyond that
this is like the prestige where it was
just hugh jackman's body floating in a
tank the whole time
very warhol asked that sounds great
yikes um no but one of the things
so great about inception is that ending
which is that you know people like to
know what you know
is he in a dream is he not in a dream
did it wobble did it fall did it fall
out the screen went to blank and the
answer ultimately is it doesn't matter
because the ending is the ending is the
ending that's how the movie ends i think
we can all agree that none of us want to
see what happens when and if the top
stops spinning like it's wouldn't that
be great if the sequel if the sequel was
just a top spinning for 90 minutes
honestly i would not put that past
sir christopher nolan i don't think he's
a knight i'm just calling him that
anyway but he will be
yeah he will be um i wouldn't that
wouldn't surprise me at all
or two or they do it like clue where
there's two different movies right yeah
one of them just happens like this yeah
the top is spinning for 90 minutes and
the other one is the top
falls immediately yeah and it's just
laying on a table for 90 minutes by the
way that's also a movie i'm glad i
didn't get a sequel is clue a perfect
film another good one another good
example of a great a great move and
again like clue is the kind of thing
that you could do a hundred times and it
would be different every time it would
be fun and funny and great every time
although you couldn't
do that movie again because that cast is
perfect no it's lightning in a bottle
and much like logan lucky it was a flop
and so yes they were never gonna make a
sequel because it did so poorly right an
incredible flop that nobody at the time
and weirdos like us watched it on tv
right and it became a cult classic and
now flames on the side of my face
greatest gift ever made yeah yeah
i just love to see i love the little bit
where martin maul's like does anyone
want a drink and a bunch of people want
drinks and he's just like pours foods
all over the glass just like i just like
anything madeleine khan does in that
whole movie like when she just runs
around making or any more squeaky noises
or any movie already yeah she's perfect
yeah
no liquid leather is a good one yeah
logan lucky for that same reason yeah
yeah
clueless
i don't want to see that sequel where
she and although josh break up in
college they did they did have a tv
spin-off so i know i watched it
so now
that brings up a good point because a
lot of the one a lot of the movies that
we've been talking about
i only bring this up
by the way just side note just an idea
for later maybe we all get a button
called the comment blocker uh where
it makes a loud noise and we're allowed
to interrupt each other when we're when
we just want to correct we don't we
don't want to be rude but we need to
correct something really quickly because
we know that the youtube comment section
is going to fill up
with
talking about like uh actually
i think what really happened with
casablanca casablanca had a tv show they
made a tv show uh following up the
adventures of rick uh
in his uh in in his part at rick's uh
was
what was the uh
yeah no it does i don't know if it made
it past pilate but uh i will say i did i
watched the clueless series but it was
uh it was bad uh like donald faison was
on it and the girl who played amber was
on it and i think those were the only
two people who came back from the movie
but it was a it was a bad show people
who liked paychecks yeah man the name of
the casablanca tv show is called
casablanca
original it was from 1983. so you
mentioned a few movies but i don't think
you've gone into any of your picks so
what what are some movies that you would
are glad don't have sequels
speaking to what we were talking about
the the one that i picked that comes off
of uh the the article
that we have uh it is something that
there have been other projects
associated with it they've been kind of
like unofficial sequels to it and a lot
of plays and uh it helps that i think
it's i think it whoops into the public
domain a while ago so uh
but uh it's a wonderful life it's a
wonderful life classic movie
beautiful ending wonderful story any
continuation of it that i can think of
aside from doing
like a comedy version
like a series of
vignettes
yeah no totally right but like uh
like unless you turned it into an
anthology series where it's you know
sure angel's going around well that's
touched by an angel uh
which is a perfect show that nobody ever
had any complaints about
uh i was thinking about i was trying to
figure out how you would do a sequel to
it's a wonderful life and
the unfortunate fact of the matter is
that it's a story about a guy who is
told by god that he's pretty good that
he's a pretty great dude
and i can't imagine that that does
anything good to a person's psyche right
like there's no way that he became a
better person because of that right like
that's a lot of confidence to pile the
one dude right so i feel like i don't
know i caught up with that character
later no please i mean
the premise of the good place though is
that a godlike figure tells somebody
you're great and you belong in the good
place and he's using that in that false
information to torture her and then she
eventually becomes a better person as to
all the rest of them
right well he's doing that specifically
to torture her though this this is right
but then they actually all right i feel
sorry for a guy so he's like hey man
yeah you know you actually you know i
bet you're all right i bet you're okay
yeah
there's other implications to it too
clarence the angel uh that gets sent
down like pretty clearly a
barely functional alcoholic throughout
the whole thing right and like and then
they give him wings and
isn't the implication in that that that
guardian angels do that kind of thing
all the time
yeah and that this is the action that
gives them their wings so i mean right
there you have and you have an it's a
wonderful life cinematic universe
already unfolding
totally yeah
yeah
it sounds boring and bad but yeah yeah
yeah i mean someone won't really make it
it really only works once
yeah yeah yeah really nice story but
i don't know yeah there's there's
nowhere to take that right
like at best you find out that
i don't know
well and it's also like i mean tom you
mentioned like what a sweet kind of
heartwarming story it is and so yeah a
sequel at any time about any member of
the family would feel so soulless like
what a cash grab it would be
like that's that's the bigger thing for
me here's how you do a sequel
george bailey is dead
he is now an angel assigned to it's a
wonderful life someone
okay but he's really not good at it and
people keep jumping to their deaths
so then they resend a new angel to show
george
that things would be much worse if he
weren't an angel
isn't this also just kind of the plot of
soul
i don't remember
wait a minute so are you saying that
they send an angel to convince george
that the world is better with the people
that he got killed dead
yeah
like he's an angel of death that's going
down and like inadvertently pushing
people over the edge i have an idea
what if i haven't really thought he
finds dead people and they whisper help
me and then he gets transported back to
the day of their death god is my witness
[Laughter]
i will never stop pitching true calling
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
video we love you bye
[Music]